je suis allé faire le disney blabla
nommé pu moi j'ai pas fait mais pubiens
tous les imageurs je te laisse l'antenne
pour une fois un système de débrouille
toi le temps des frères mes très chers
frères rien de tel pour récurer les
ciboires que la crème du vrai curé
clergé avec clerget votre ciboire
s'éclaire d'un jet la crème du vrai curé
est en vente dans toutes les bonnes
sacristie c'est la volonté les qui vous
le dis il faut engager été plus ben
c'est tout ce que tu as nancy g celle du
papier tu vois ce que je veux dire
abattus si elle est un peu quand on sait
que moi ton pusterla 19 de la championne
a rangé ses glisser des petits papiers
papier toilette pour fès douillet c'est
moins austère qu'elle pas qu'il devait
lui tous ces cas récent site absorbant
c'est moins ban avec une papier journal
c'est moins glacée tel papier monnaie
mais on s'en fout c'est bien envoyé
c'est vous qui bricole et le dimanche
après la messe utiliser la passe
monseigneur lefebvre et vous ne paierez
plus votre latin avec la pince
monseigneur lefebvre le bricolage viana
avec la place monseigneur lefebvre le
bricolage devient vrai paradis elle vous
fera gagner du temps et vous pourriez
enfin coincé ainsi soit-il le monsieur
si votre femme est ronchon quand elle a
fini son ménage c'est qu'il lui manque
un bon ballet offrez-lui un ballet
corded le ballet cordy enlève la
poussière comme une tornade crise le
ballet cordy est en vente dans toutes
les bonnes émissions c'est un produit
carpentier